and what that means is that you need
every company you invest in to be able
to get to about 100 million a year in
revenue what do you look for when you
when you talk to the founders you know
how do you make your decision if you're
gonna if you're going to make the
investment or not so here's what I said
I said you know there's a million
intangible signals that you're thinking
about and going over but really you know
it boils down to the following does this
person know what the hell they're
talking about when I talk to them do I
get this sense of confidence and
certainty that's not about the style of
the speech but that the things they're
saying actually makes sense and when you
push and probe a little bit you can tell
that they've already thought through
those things they have a thoughtful
answer about it and they know more about
the subject they know but they know if
so much about the subject which is what
you should expect from somebody who's
building a company in a space the next
thing I think about is are they an
executor or just a talker of course you
want an executor are they all in on this
or are they doing this as a side project
do they have a habit of quitting
projects or habit of splitting focus
like you know I don't want somebody
invest in to go have a podcast and go
speak at conferences and do all this
other I mean some people get caught
up in that and there's a reason I
started this podcast after I sold my
company not during the last thing I
really think about is are they in touch
with reality or they a delusional
optimist what what I mean by that is do
they actually understand the main risk
and challenge of their business so like
have they correctly identified what the
big challenge is to make their their
vision come true and are they thinking
about you know do they appropriately
assess that risk there's a lot of people
who don't have a credible view of
reality they're out of touch with
reality you know you bring something up
that's a risk they they just don't think
it's a risk and I think that's that can
be a very very big problem and so you
know the overwhelming feeling I get when
I walk away from those conversations is
either wow this person had a lot of
clarity and quality of thought about
their business or they don't and I
basically just don't invest if they
don't have clarity or quality of
thinking around their business you know
the other thing that I sort of think
about is
you know what have you done in your past
so a track record of doing interesting
and unique stuff does tend to carry
forward throughout your life and so
sometimes somebody has zero experience
in a given domain but I look at their
background and they also went into other
things with zero experience and came out
six months later as a winner as it being
a leader in a space and so I think that
looking at somebody's track record for
success is obviously a good sign just
because they don't have it doesn't mean
it's it's a bad it doesn't mean you know
you eliminate them but it is obviously a
huge huge factor if you can do it and
the other thing is you know the question
I got no this will be the last thing on
angel investing is what are the type of
returns you're looking forward some
people think and Sam often talks about
like he loves great businesses that are
like the hustle so this is actually a
good example so when Sam started the
hustle I had an opportunity to invest
Kassam was a friend and at that point I
had learned invest in your friends think
of yourself as an investor but I went to
the hustles office which was this like
you know tiny rinky-dink place and they
sat me down they walked me through the
vision and I thought to myself this is
totally gonna work and I totally don't
want to invest am I thinking was I don't
think this type of business will
generate the type of returns I'm looking
for so what do I mean by that angel
investing works best when you put small
checks into many companies and you're
not looking for what the sort of median
return is but you're looking for what
the maximum return is you basically need
two or three winners in your portfolio
to make everything else a rounding error
and what that means is that you need
every company you invest in to be able
to get to about 100 million a year in
revenue 100 million a year in revenue is
a hot there's a billion dollar company
and this isn't about greed it's about
the risk and reward profile the risk is
so high that you need winners to pay off
so so well to justify the risk that
you're taking because you're taking both
you're taking risk and in liquidity
right a startup that you invest in is
probably not going to be liquid for
seven to ten years
and so if you have a liquid if you have
an illiquid investment that's extremely
high-risk you need to pay off to be huge
to make up for those two downsides I'll
give you an example with lambda school I
realized pretty quickly I was like okay
so it sounds like the average student is
worth what you know $25,000 for you okay
so you need 4,000 students in a in a
year to generate you about a hundred
million dollars okay four thousand
students I believe you can get there
that's not a crazy number
that's not four hundred thousand so
there's not four million students four
hundred thousand I think four huh I
think four thousand students will take
you up on this offer at the time that I
invested
I think lambda school at that time had
graduated maybe 81 people total you know
there wasn't anyone wasn't four thousand
but it was clear to me that four
thousand was an achievable number and
that four thousand would get them to the
point where they're somewhere between
fifteen hundred million dollar revenue
business depending on what the value per
student was was going to end up being
and so that was believable and that that
alone was enough justification to say
write the check in addition to Austin's
an incredible founder he spoke very
clearly about what he was doing there
was clearly evidence that their approach
was different than other people's
approach and might get a different
result than what other people other
companies in the space have gotten for
example most of the coding boot camps
were in person and lame to school was
online most of the coding boot camps
were in a very short period three to
three months and lame the school was
like a nine-month program and what ended
up happening was that most online
learning things had like a 95% dropout
rate people did not complete the course
and lambda school had like I don't know
what the exact numbers were but eighty
to ninety percent of people finish the
program and eighty to ninety percent of
them got jobs typing jobs and so I was
like whoa they've you know those are
amazing signals and I believe that they
can get to 4,000 students I believe they
can give that experience to 4000
students which would get them into a
hundred-million-dollar year range so
that's what type of returns you look for
and so I assume that in a batch of 30
companies three of them will drive 95 to
99 percent of all the returns
I hope that in the end this Nets out
into you know I put in let's call it
500,000 and I I basically quadrupled to
5x my money over the seven-year period
and so you know five hundred thousand in
and let's say at five exit that's 2.5
million at out and you know this is not
like the biggest craziest life change
ever but there's a chance it's much more
if you hit one of the real winners then
you know I've seen a $25,000 check turn
into twenty five million that can happen
but you you know I would say the average
or they sort of expected return of what
I would call the minimum bar of success
as to four or five X my money over a
seven-year period which Nets out I think
to like I don't know like a twenty
percent IRR or something like that
[Music]
you